we're going to take a look at some viral
videos and Tick Tock videos the kids are
passing around on the internet this week
these are videos that have been sent to
me by my producers specifically McKenna
and she has sent me a lot of Dylan
Mulvaney stuff because uh I guess she
you know as usual is trying to get me
into even more trouble so I'm only
looking at the description here and uh
so I could they send me this clip sheet
this is all
so clip 20 Dylan wraps about being a
girl
okay it's day 200 of
the girl and I think we can agree that
it's been a whirlwind I have a tendency
to over share my life and y'all are
still watching how cool is that once
upon a time I was a boy who had ADHD and
now I'm a girl who still has ADHD I
really like possums and Twilight and
pretzels I accidentally became an
influencer now here we are girlhood has
had its ups and its downs and here's
what I've learned so far
women are awesome but can also be cruel
I'm doing my best and boys they kind of
drool my hormones are wild and my boobs
kind of sore it's only day 200 we have
so much more to experience together
we're just getting started thank you for
being my friend you're open-hearted I
don't feel so alone no more shame and
carefree being a girl is awesome would
you agree
love ya
why would you do that to me why would
you do that to me
[Music]
uh I
think I've said all about this guy that
needs to be said or that can be said I
am interested in uh well not really
interested but I'm slightly curious
about uh I like possums and pretzels
like
the the two most random
possible thing really you like possums
what does that mean
you know what we're just gonna move on
so today was our first day back from
Spring Break and
I told all my students that my pronouns
are they them and that my honorific is
mix
a few of my students had some questions
and we were able to talk about those
um but I wanted to tell you about two of
my students that just made my heart sing
and made me feel so validated one of
them she put in the chat ah I'm so proud
of you
and then one of my other students maybe
like half an hour after we had talked
about that
had a question and put in the chat mix
here's my question
um and it was just so validating to see
mix pop up on the screen instead of Miss
and I just
it made my day
yeah it really uh it really it cannot be
emphasized enough
how
perverse I mean obviously all this is
perverse but just the very idea that
you are you are seeking validation from
kid not only kids but the kids you're
supposed to be teaching you are supposed
to be providing a service to the child
by teaching the child and and therefore
to the parents into the community like
that's what you're supposed to be doing
and yet they become forums uh or or you
you have now put on them the burden of
validation so I think we spent a lot of
time talking about how it you know being
called mix just a total gibberish it
doesn't make any sense to feel validated
by that that is a bizarre and ridiculous
thing to be validated by of course
that's true but also just just
that you want to be validated At All by
the kids that you're putting that on
them that's not their burden in fact
it's not it's not anyone's burden it's
not anyone's job to validate you in that
sense and I still I you know people
make this point all the time when we see
these videos of teachers
and um but it's a good point that I
think back to when I was a kid
and it's like you didn't know anything
about your teachers you didn't know
anything about their private life it
didn't come up they didn't talk about it
there's no reason to talk about it as
far as you were concerned your teacher
lived at the school and it's like the
teacher was like a some sort of uh
vampire or something that they carved
out from the basement and then bring up
into the classroom and then bring back
down that's what you thought it's like
as far as you're concerned the teachers
lived there and then if you if you saw a
teacher somewhere else it was all about
the grocery store if you saw them in
civilian clothes anywhere else it was
like mind-blowing and that's actually
that's how it should be because that
what that shows of course it's like as a
child that's it's a it's a it's an
absurd kind of view that you have of
your teacher but
what it shows is that there are
appropriate boundaries in place between
you
and the teacher and what this shows is
that there are no boundaries at all and
that you are seeking validation from
kids you know you should be providing
emotional support in an appropriate way
and in a in a in a properly ordered way
to the child not the other way around
you know you've heard me talk about how
important it is to have a VPN to protect
your online privacy but choosing a VPN
you trust is equally as important I like
to do my research on my sponsors and I
only recommend Brands to my listeners
that I believe in to actually stop
people from monitoring your online
activity you need to do what I do and
use expressvpn think about all the times
you've used Wi-Fi at a coffee shop Hotel
even a friend's house without expressvpn
every site you visit can be logged by
the Admin of that Network that's still
true even when you're in incognito mode
especiallypn is an app that encrypts all
of your network data and reroutes it
through a network of secure servers so
that your private online activity stays
private expressvpn works on all your
devices it's super easy to use the app
has one button you tap it to connect and
your browsing activity is secure stop
letting strangers invade your online
privacy protect yourself at
expressvpn.com
walshyt use my Link at expressvpn.com
walshyt to get three extra months free
that's exp ress VPN dot com slash
walshyt if I work somewhere and I
express to a number of people what my
pronouns are and I'm working there for
like six months
um
I shouldn't have to explicitly tell
every single person I haven't worked I
worked there for like six months or more
and neither one another one of them
okay so we have another person
complaining about uh being the shot this
actually reminded me of a video that had
a couple days ago I didn't get a chance
to play and so these two videos kind of
tie together they almost look like
similar people different hairstyle
anyway well here's another person
complaining about being misgendered and
there's an important point to be made
from this but let's let's watch this
first you know what I don't get is why
people still see me as a woman
what more could I be doing I literally
got my titties off
[Music]
I don't think I look like a woman so why
does everybody
well people still see you as a woman
because because you are one and this
only goes to show that uh it actually
does not boil down to any individual
body part
so that's what that that side accuses us
of doing that they they accuse us of
just sort of like reducing people to
their body parts and all of that you
know so when you say that well a man has
a penis they say well that's reductive
to say that's all but then of course the
the irony in the self contradiction as
always is that that's exactly what they
do because they think but we'll remove a
couple body parts or change some body
parts you know and then you're you'll
you not only will you look like the
other sex but you actually will be the
other sex we're the ones saying no it
doesn't work that way
okay now it's it's it's true that for
example men have penises that's a
correct statement
but that's not the only physical
difference between men and women
so even if a man is castrated he's still
a man and will still look like a man and
the same is true for women also because
your your entire body is a woman and uh
we can just see that we can see that in
the your shoulders we could see it in
your facial structure you know you can
see it in your hands you can see you see
it's your entire body that's what it is
and you cannot Escape it
and you shouldn't try to escape it and
also doctors shouldn't be doing that to
anyone at all especially not the kids
though which is why to bring this all
back to the beginning because this is a
this is a celebratory day at the end and
I hate to end it on such a sour note
because at least in Tennessee anyway uh
doctors will not be able to do that to
kids
um anymore
[Music]